[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENS KUEHLER: Welcome
to the session.
I hope you enjoyed
the day so far.
My name is Jens.
I'm a solution
architect at Google.
And I have with me
Raul from BT, who
is a head of [INAUDIBLE]
specialist there,
and who will talk
about that company
later and our partnership.
Today I'm going to
talk about Google Cloud
networking for enterprises.
Now, when you think about
enterprise and the cloud,
there's a few things which
are always important.
And I'm going to touch
on quite a few of them,
and how, especially
the networking part
of Google's cloud can
help you with them.
One of them is scaling
your application.
That's very important.
That's why you come to the
cloud in the first place.
One is how you keep
all of that secure.
Then always, when you
talk to enterprises,
you don't move
everything at once.
So you want to
securely connect both
the old and the new environment.
And then, as a
last thing, I will
talk about virtual private
cloud, which is a concept which
came over the last few years.
And how we are simplifying
it a little bit.
And after that, Raul will talk
about hybrid infrastructure,
hybrid cloud
infrastructure, which
is also on top of
[INAUDIBLE] enterprise.
But let's start with scale.
Let's say you build
an application
in the cloud, a
multi-tier application,
there's a few things you
generally care about.
The first is it needs to be
globally available everywhere
for users around the
globe at a low latency.
It needs to be reliable,
always available.
You want to order scale with
your demands up and down.
And you want to optimize
it for cost as well.
And then, the best,
if it's portable.
So in case you're not happy,
you can move to another cloud,
or you can even on premise.
And how we do that in
Google Cloud Platform
is with some of those
products listed here.
A Cloud Load Balancing, our
CDN, I will talk about now.
Our interconnect I will
talk in the extra part.
And then you need some kind
of Google Cloud product
to actually run the application.
This can be anything,
can be contained
an engine with Kubernetes
to be super portable.
But it can also be
just virtual machines,
managed instance groups,
any of those products.
Let's start with global.
You want to have users around
the globe for your application.
And that's where Google Cloud
Platform with the network
can help you, because we
have a global infrastructure.
Here you see green dots.
These are the
regions we currently
are found our platform where
you can run virtual machines.
And we have blue dots, which are
regions which we will open over
the course of 2017 and 2018.
But what's really
important is the gray dots
and the blue lines.
Because that's our
point of presence
which are interconnected
via our network.
And your users will always enter
the network at a close point--
closest point to their
location, regardless of where
the data is sitting.
And we have over 100 of
them around the globe.
And over 80 of them run what
we call the Google Front
End, which is where
load balancing happens.
So, when you want to load
balance you applications,
we have five flavors
of load balancing.
But today I want to talk
about global load balancing.
There, we have HTTP, HTTPS load
balancing for HTTP workloads.
For other secure workloads,
we have an SSL proxy.
And then we have a TCP proxy
for unencrypted traffic.
And all of those use what I just
called out, the Google Front
End, which we have
in over 80 locations.
Now lets look at this in detail.
On the left, you see a
traditional load balancer here.
And on the right,
you see how this
works on Google Cloud Platform.
You don't really see
a load balance at all.
You have these Google
Front Ends sitting
at the edge of our
network around the globe.
And they all sync with each
other over global control
plane, and talk to
each other and know
where there's
available capacities
to serve your application.
So they can direct your users
to the closest available data
center.
Now, that means that
users in California
can access the service you
have deployed in the US.
Users in London get
routed automatically
to your VMs in Europe.
And users in Asia
get automatically
routed to VMs there.
What's different from
other clouds as well is we
don't use DNS for
load balancing this.
You get one single IP around
the globe for all of this.
And you can have this
now on IPv4 and now
as well on IPv6 and better.
Now once you have your
application and your load
balancing set up, you might
want to optimize more for cost
or even more for latency.
And caching and CDN makes
absolute sense for that.
In Google Cloud, we have
two options for that.
You can use Google Cloud CDN.
You can activate that
with a single click.
It's integrated with
our load balancer.
Or if you already have an
existing contract with a CDN
provider and need some
advanced features,
you can use any of our
partner CDN providers,
and we give you a discounted
rate for egress to those.
Now you have the
application running.
It's load balanced.
It's caching.
But a multi-tiered
application, you
need to talk to services within
your network with each other.
And you don't want to
expose those via public IP.
So you have the same
load balancing scale.
You have externally as well
by an internal load balancer.
To run this, we use a
technology called Andromeda.
Now what is Andromeda?
It's our software defined
networking infrastructure
we built especially for
Google Computer Engine.
And that allows us for
faster startup times,
for high speed and low latency.
And we can quickly
include and augment
our network
virtualization functions,
such as firewall
I'm talking about
later, on that internal
load balancing.
We ran through
several iterations
of the Andromeda data plane
in the last few years.
Currently, we're rolling out
Andromeda 2.1, which helps
you bypass the hypervisor.
So you can talk directly
to the network interface
cards on the machine
in the user space.
And we want to bypass
that directly so you
can talk directly to
the physical hardware
from your virtual machine
in a future iteration.
Now what does that mean for you?
This makes it possible
for us to increase
the speed you get between VMs.
You can now get up to
16 gigabit per seconds.
It leads to lower latency.
But one thing which
is often overlooked
is it also leads to less CPU
consumption, on the host, where
we run the VM, and on
your VM guest machine.
And that means, if you
have network and CPU
intensive applications, they run
much more smoothly than before.
Now this is how we can help
you scale the application.
Let's talk about security.
Because this is really on
top of mind for enterprises.
In a traditional environment
when you think about security,
you think about routers,
firewalls, DDoS protections,
and a lot of boxes like IDS,
IPS, WAF application firewalls.
Lots of this is virtualized
in the Google Cloud.
So let's look at them, and how
you can move those concepts
over to the Google Cloud.
The first thing is
routing and switching.
In a traditional
environment, traffic
comes from the internet, and
moves through several layers
until it gets to the top of
rack switch, and in the end,
to your physical host.
In the Google
Cloud Platform, you
have machines talking
to each other.
But the network
infrastructure in between
is completely virtualized.
It's run through our
software defined networking.
So you don't have to
configure anything there.
And you don't have to care where
the machines are physically
located at all.
But if you want to do some
advanced functionality,
advanced routing.
For example, you want
to push some traffic
to a certain address
range through a gateway,
you can do that with
advanced routing range
rules as well, virtualized.
We all of-- we put these
things in place seamlessly
through our software
defined network.
In a typical data
center network,
firewalls are often
a choke point.
Because firewall capacity
is not the same capacity
as the rest of the network.
Now, if you think back
on the previous slide,
there was no firewall
at all listed
in the Google Cloud Platform.
That's because it's distributed.
And it's on every single host.
We distribute the firewall, and
it's enforced at a host level.
Now in the past, you had
firewalls on Google Cloud
Platform so you could save which
traffic can come into a VM.
But we recently
added new feature.
One is, you can now
control traffic outgoing
from a VM egress firewalls.
And as well, you can set
permit and deny rules.
So you can have rules
overlapping each other,
and set those with a priority,
which would get then looked
at in sequence.
So you can do the same kind of
complex access control lists
you used to form on premise.
You can now move those
more or less one to one
to the Google Cloud Platform.
If you think about distributed
denial of service attacks,
you will be happy to hear that
if you either use Google Cloud
load balancer or
Google Cloud CDN,
we have a built in layer
three, layer four DDoS defense
already.
And our global high speed
and high capacity network
makes sure that we
can absorb attacks
of any kind of size and scale.
Now, if that's not
enough for you,
and if you want
additional protection,
you can use any of our third
party DDoS protection partners,
and put an additional
layer of defense in.
Now when you have
all this in place,
you might still want some
specialized security appliance,
or you're already tied
very closely to a vendor.
Let's say, for example, you
want to put a web application
firewall in place.
Or you're used to running
Checkpoint firewall,
and you want to use the
same rules in the cloud you
use on premise.
Now I'm happy to announce that
most of the major appliance
vendors now offer a virtualized
version of their appliances,
which you can launch easily
with a few clicks in our Google
Cloud Cloud Launcher.
So to recap, security
is a layered approach.
And this is the
same way we see it.
At the core, you have a
secure, virtual private cloud.
You have distributed firewall.
You have identity and
access management.
And a lot of other
features, some
of which I will touch
on a little bit later.
Then, around this, you have
a secure interconnection,
which I will now go into.
You can have third party
virtual appliances,
adding even extra
features to that.
And then you have
our load balancer,
which has practically
unlimited capacity for you,
and has built in layer three,
layer four DDoS protection.
Around all that, we have
our global Google network,
which can absorb any kind,
style, and kind of attack.
And then, as an outer layer
of defense, you can use this--
another third party DDoS defense
mechanism on top of that,
if you wish.
Now we talked about scale.
We talked about security.
But you also want
to know how you
want to interconnect your
own existing environment
with the Google Cloud.
And I'm happy to tell you
that this got a lot easier.
We used to have only
these three mechanism.
We have a direct
peering mechanism,
where you meet us in one
of our points of presence,
around the globe.
You have a carrier
interconnect functionality,
where you use a
partner such as BT
to provide a service for you.
But all of us only provided a
public view into our products,
like over public IP addresses.
And the only way you had
to connect privately to us
was via VPN tunnels.
The advantage we have, this
private interconnect service
actually gives you access
to all Google services.
So not only Google
Cloud Platform, but also
all G-suite services, like
Docs and Sheets and Mail.
But even our consumer services,
as YouTube, et cetera,
are available over that link.
But for private access,
you will limit it to VPN.
We do have a high
availability option
there. so you can have
one or multiple tunnels.
So you can have a
secure and stable link.
But what enterprises are looking
for are usually an easier way.
So I'm happy to announce
that we will soon
be offering Google Cloud
Interconnect, which provides
a private access of
private IP addresses
directly into your project
from your enterprise.
Which enables an easy
hybrid cloud deployment.
And you don't need
a VPN anymore.
And we offer this
in two flavors.
Private interconnect
or partner connect.
Now let's look at
this in detail.
Private interconnect
means, you met us
at one of our core location
facilities around the globe.
And you put your
peering router there,
and you interconnect with us.
And we drop you directly
into your project.
Now partner
interconnect means, you
have a service provider
partner in-between,
which might be already
in our facility.
So the service
provider can meet you
where you are located, like at
your enterprise headquarters,
or your existing data center.
And depending on the
service, you might not even
need a router in place.
But you just get an
ethernet connection which
drops you into your project.
Now we offer a
private interconnect
at launch in all the green
locations around the globe.
So in Europe, that's London,
Amsterdam, Frankfurt.
But later this year, we
will expand this further
to more locations,
including Madrid.
Now once you have a private
interconnect like that,
you want to also have
this in a reliable way.
Unfortunately, on
a single circuit,
we cannot offer you any type
of SLA because just the fiber
might be cut.
Someone might trip
over the cable.
This is not possible.
But as soon as you have two
lengths in one location,
we can offer you a 99.9%
availability SLA in that.
If you go globally, and you have
several interconnections to us
cross sides, we can offer you
up 5/9 of availability for this.
Now we talked about scale.
We talked about security.
And we talked about how you can
interconnect with our network.
Now I want to take a few
minutes to talk and show you
how we evaluated the concept
of virtual private cloud, which
came up in the
industry, and what
we thought about how we
could make this a little bit
different.
Now, if you think about
a virtual private cloud,
there's a few things
which sets us apart.
One, that it's global.
So you can have a single
virtual private cloud
which spans across many
regions, even across the globe.
It's shareable.
And I will go into detail and
show you what that means later.
It's expandable.
That means you don't have to
set your network addressing
in stone.
You can easily change it later.
And I will also demo that.
And you can have
a private access
to other Google services.
Now let's go a bit into
detail into all of that.
Now when I talk
about a global VPC,
we need to look at a
traditional VPC first.
Traditionally, virtual
private clouds are regional.
So once you expand your Google--
your cloud usage
to another region,
you might have to set
up an interconnection
between these regions,
either over the internet,
over the VPN, or
via other means.
It's not automatic.
Now with Google Cloud, this
has always been automatic.
You can easily
access your machines,
your virtual machines,
which are located
in another region
around the globe.
You can-- there's no extra--
there's no extra configuration
required for that.
And the traffic
all flows securely
through our Google
owned backbone network.
Now the big difference
between or VPC
and some other
virtual private cloud
is also that our VPC can be
shared across an organization.
Now, when you look
at other VPCs,
it's kind of, for developers,
very hard to use the cloud.
Because they might not be
networking specialists.
They might not know
how to use the network.
They're actually coming from
an on premise environment,
and they never had to
care about the network.
So why do they
suddenly have to set up
firewall rules or routing rules
or interconnection VPNs, et
cetera?
Now luckily, since
in Google, we offer
shared VPC, or
cross-product network,
you can have one
virtual network which
spans across your
whole organization
and where you provide
the network as a service
to your developers,
which might still
be in separate projects for
administration and billing
purposes.
Now let's look at
this in a detail.
You have an organization
where all your projects sit.
And in this
organization, you create
a project which will be the
shared VPC host network.
And that one has the
security and a network admin,
which care for all
the firewall rules,
the routing rules, and the
secure interconnection,
back to your premises.
Then in this shared network,
you can create subnets.
And you can share those subnets
across different projects.
So you can add projects to this.
Let's say you have different
groups working on rep service,
recommendations and analytics.
And all of those need
to talk to each other.
But centrally, it's decided
who creates those rules.
So the for the product member,
that's also an advantage.
Because they get a network
as a plug and play.
They need to care--
don't need to care
about the metric security.
They don't need to care
about a private and secure
interconnection.
Now sometimes, you need to
interconnect to other networks
in Google Cloud, which might
not be in your organization.
Or you want to do
it the other way,
where actually, the
project owner wants
to set the networking rules.
So for those people, we also
offer a more traditional VPC
network peering,
where one project says
he wants to talk to
Project B. Project B
says he wants to
talk to Project A.
And we put a secure interconnect
over a software defined network
in place that you can
talk to each other
privately without going
through public IP addresses.
There's even a third way.
And that is that you can
have now this multi neck.
You can have one VM.
Have multiple network
interface cards.
And those can be in
different networks.
So, this is, for
example, used in many
of the virtual appliances
I talked about earlier.
Last but not least, I want to
talk about the private access
to Google services.
Now, often enough,
you want to run
some back end calculations,
or some micro services,
which don't need--
shouldn't talk to
the outside world.
They shouldn't have a public IP.
But you still want to make use
of all the Google services.
Just cloud storage,
cloud logging,
BigQuery, or any of the others.
So, this was very
difficult in the past.
Because you talk over
public IPs to those.
With private access
to Google services,
you can enable that although
these virtual machines
don't have a private IP--
don't have a public
IP, they can still
talk to other resources
on Google Cloud Platform.
Now I want to take that a little
bit into practice and demo
this.
So let me show you a
little scenario we have.
Let's say we have
this scenario where
you have three teams, one
working on the web server,
one working on the
recommendation engine,
and one working on
the analytics, who
use a lot of BigQuery.
Now in a traditional
VPC, you would put all
of those in different projects.
And then, to talk
to each other, you
need to put
interconnects into place
between all these projects.
You need to put
connections into place
from each of those projects
back to your on premise network.
And you somehow need
to make sure you
can talk to our other services.
Now with the features
I just explained,
let's take a step back.
What you actually
want to achieve.
You just want to talk
securely between the projects,
securely back home.
And you want to talk securely
to other Google Cloud Services.
How you do that
with Google Cloud
with VPC's is you still
have the different teams
and different projects.
They get their separate
bills split out.
You can set ident access--
access to those separately.
But you have one shared
virtual private cloud,
one cross project networking
spanning all of those projects.
You have a secure
connection to Cloud BigQuery
over private access.
And you also have a private
interconnect in place
back to your on premise network.
Only one.
And the developers
just have to care
about setting up their machines
and setting up their service.
Now let's show you how this
looks like in our environment.
So this is our Google
Cloud Platform dashboard.
And this is the networking page.
So, there's actually
two kinds of networks.
There's automatic
networks, where
we set up some sub
networks for you
around the globe, one
in each of our regions.
And then there's the
second way, which
is custom networking,
which you see on the bottom
where we set up--
where you set up the networking
and the addressing yourself.
Now, let me show
you how easy you
can add a sub network to this.
So I go into the network.
I say I want to add a subnet.
Let's say our
developers came and say
they want the test environment.
So I call the subnet
network Def test.
I need to say in
which region it is.
Let's say Europe.
And I need to give it
an IP address range.
I give it 100000/24.
I hit Add.
And I added a new sub network.
Now I want to give all
the developers access
to my sub network
over share VPC.
So I go into share
VPC, and I start--
still there.
Let me delete it and show
you something else quickly.
This is the demo.
So let me start from scratch.
This takes about a second.
Let's say in the meantime,
the developers come back.
And they say, what did you do?
You gave us just 200
addresses, just 200 VM--
250 addresses.
We need more than
250 VMs for testing.
Give us a few more.
So what we will do, we
can just easily say,
OK, I made a mistake.
I gave them only a
slash 24 network.
I go back and I select a
different subnet range.
And I say I want to extend
this network, not 100000/24,
but slash 16.
So now they can use up
to 65,000 addresses.
I hope that should be enough.
Now while this is
creating, let me finally
step through the
Wizard and set up
the cross-product networking.
Now first step to enable
cross-product networking, is
you need to enable a
project as a host project.
So I want to say, this
is my host project.
This is the project where
the security firewall network
administration will happen.
I do this.
I save.
And then the next
step, I need to say,
which subnets do I want to
share with another environment?
I can either select them one by
one, analytics for an analytics
project, etc.
For purposes of the demo,
I will just share them all.
And I continue.
OK?
And then, the last
step is, I need
to say with which projects do
I want to share the network?
So I will use my analytics
recommendation and web server
project.
I save this.
And now the cross project
networking is put into place.
Now we create a
secure connection
that from the other
projects you can
create virtual machines
automatically and easily
in this project.
Now how does this look like?
Let me switch to
another project.
Let's say I'm a developer
on the analytics team,
and I want to create
a virtual machine.
So I go to Compute Engine.
VM instances.
I say I want to
create a new instance.
Let's call it analytics 1.
I want to have this in Europe.
Again.
And, under networking, I can
select now in which network
this lies.
It's right now in
the default network.
And here, I can select I
want to actually put it
in a network which
was shared with me.
And I want to select
the analytics network,
because I'm a member
of the analytics team.
And that's all I need to do.
I create-- I create
the VM just normally.
And then, all the other
teams can access it
according to the rules which
were centrally defined.
So this is how easily you
can create a shared network
and share it across different
teams and different projects.
Now to recap, we have a
global virtual private cloud,
with private connectivity and
private access to other Google
services.
We have it shareable, so you can
share across different teams.
And you can use a shared
interconnection to your
on premise environment.
And we have it expandable.
You don't need to do the
whole planning ahead of time.
You can expand the IP address
ranges at a later stage.
And that's some
of the advantages
Google virtual private
cloud provides for us.
And with this, I
want to give over
to Raul, who will talk
about BT's approach to build
your hybrid infrastructure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAUL CHICO: Thank you Jens.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]